pensate a tutti i ragazzi che questo
nuovo video sono bravi j
oggi siamo tornati su paint the crown
era un mese che non faccio un episodio
su pen the town red perché avevo finito
tutti i livelli mi avete detto ragazzi
che è uscito un nuovo livello a meno che
non mi state trovandole colonial
chronicle questa roba qua è uscita in
teoria dovrebbe essere ragazzi
ambientati in una nave nel 1726 non ho
idea di che salve a c'è anche la nave ma
non è una nave era mosso come andiamo ce
lo facciamo sto bicchierino di rum
insieme ci hai voglia fare un brindisi
amico mio
dream da sei stronzo allora un brindisi
dei faccin cin
e poi beviamo sia niente la gara non
c'ha voglia di far brindisi però io
entro vediamo non penso che sta gente
voglia fare a botte non sembrano
incazzati vero 0 salve è che bello anche
il barman design pronto lì coi castle
fianchi o io non ho fatto un cazzo è
prendo anche un po di birra grazie che
un tempo che salverà madonna tu con la
mannaia già lui c'è già la mannaia
ragazzi perché è incazzato nero è nero
quindi incazzato nero non posso andare
in acqua
ok livello di riprodurre vuol dire
testarda niente ragazzi fatevi vedere la
nave come me sa cioè che capitano che
figo si è appena ucciso da solo
infilandosi la lama nel petto però vabbè
io inizierei proprio prendendo lui se
siete d'accordo ci siete come cazzo c.so
finito qua sopra
per quale motivo è successa questa cosa
c'è un fucile è cosa troppo [ __ ]
la chiosa ragazzi siamo partiti vedo che
si ammazzano tutti a caso senza motivo
devo scendere aiuto come cazzo dicendo
che a merda come fatta sia qua sopra ha
versato su tizio soca alla madonna
madonna che bordello cioè il capitano il
capitano che sta aspettando la faccia un
tizio che non sta morendo non so come
perché ce l'hai con me cosa ho fatto
non so che messi molto bene perché
quello che non c'è un braccio a calcio
un tizio che non ci andrà ecco adesso
vanno morto che a me va bene che mi
suicidio
[Musica]
da ricordare che a soli abbiamo
scherzato adesso facciamo i culi come si
deve ma [ __ ]
lui è sempre incazzato nero è la madonna
vuoi fare tour brindisi mi manca
bicchiere però ragazzi miei sembra più
incasinato degli altri questo lo so
perché ma è troppo dispersiva st mappa è
una pagaia ipia pagaia ti rinfaccia
bellissimi cache volta kam air da
ragazzo dio vuole minchia come che si è
fatto anche lui sa saltare oddio se le
gambe a te posso spingere giorni
[Musica]
la mano amica che cazzo sei renegade
mega la gente che si alza la terra anche
se morta fantastico di zombie la
bottigliata regalo zio shockwave ready
non lo faccio lo faccio qui tutti morti
madonna è caccia allo squalo quanto
fatto bene sto livello rispetto agli
altri è bellissima il più bel livello di
cazzo fate come fa vj a pagaiate
risolvete i problemi adesso ho capito me
spingere la gente giu quindi fermi un
attimo di faccio venire qua
siete vis nova bara [ __ ] a posso
metterci giorno avete un giorno die
linke più figo è la madonna adesso vedo
che attrae quant'è difficile al volo al
volo
porca [ __ ] sono morti tutti e due
fantastico posso comprare la vita che
sto tipo già meno di metà vita 120
quell'ora la faccia sul tavolo
[Musica]
mi diverte troppo spingere la gente non
lo so perché vale cazzo sei uscito ok ma
la vita e la spada che ti si è ficcata
nel cranio che mi serve un over vai vai
vai vai varedo tornare su pos dovrai su
come ho fatto a salire ecco o dio quanto
lucano io posso posso scendere dal cielo
senza ma riccato su superman
vabbè era lui il superman
e vabbè non stop a separare le porte
tipo morto fosse nota che non posso
entrare sei morto non è morto ma se c'è
una spada conficcato nell'ano cosa stai
dicendo fortuna che sa di essere un
albergo mi fa cagare
oddio veramente no amiche possibile
addio quanta gente che lo stai facendo
state cominciando i due devono vincere
che un'arma io possa usare
tranquillamente
salve mi sa che lui è un nemico si è
incazzato adesso incazzato perché merda
eads io no ma certo è rimasto vivo come
è possibile cioè se batto il capitano
dovrei aver vinto ma non ce la farò mai
lo so già cominciava la mannaia la
mannaia no che mi sono incastrato scazzo
morto sono molto molto inca strettissimo
nero sapevo li mortacci tua dopo ragazzi
questa è quella buona
me lo sento
ci sono incazzati sti due ragazzi si
sono incazzati sti due che sono
abbastanza forti credo
stavo scherzando caprai eva quanto ma
tolto ma tolto tutta la vita anzi la
pagaia e più grossa di tua madre mi
piace mira veramente lo presero scusate
scusate non volevo è la madonna romeo
giulietta
[Applauso]
e sì l'ho preso da un chilometro e mezzo
uno scopo
no ma che culo è mai giù bastardo vai
giù è rimasto lì ok ragazzi ve ne
mancano tipo pochissimi pochissimi un
cap cioè la ragazzina mira me ne mancano
veramente pochi ho fatto fuori quasi
tutti sono arrivati più in alto di me
prima ora quello dove si è salvata come
co cosa fai fluttui come faro è
possibile ragazzi ha barato a varazze
perdo non è vero perché a baratto
kesicki casco cristiano non muore ma
cos'è e daje c'è verso senti capito che
sei il boss di turno e che quindi ci
mette di più accadere ma porca [ __ ]
ma guarda guarda quello cosa c'è in
bocca e muori
minchia un'ora e mezza grazie dell'arma
che mi lascia la radio su ali manca
veramente un cazzo non so quanti mancano
questi qua per forza 987 colossale nel
culo rientrata certo ce mancava quello
che google è al culo grosso che
rientrano pure le spade ok ragazzo a
quel è morto nessuno però pazienza dai
54 dai dai
ma qua mi chiamo forza società bistecca
c'aveva capitano con la bistecca
spiegatemi il senso della bistecca 32
una crepa
[ __ ] non regala l'ultimo devo far
morire bene dove lo faccio morire
l'ultimo sapere anche qua sopra ma vero
non mi chiami porca torneo no minchia
seno ammazzavano o ragazzi ma mancava
tanto così mi ammazzava lui a si è ri
figlia di mick e incredibile ci siamo
ragazzi ho vinto devo scappare con la
nave però ci sente messa seccato sul
pontile adesso ci avete sperato e per un
attimino maledetti ce l'ho fatta ragazza
65 sono 65 gli squali sono più saggi di
prima ha scommesso una vita e mezza da
gava che questa
20 caseina tissimo però è stato figo vi
ringrazio per avermi consigliato anche
la mappa della casa era vuota
i pirati a caso se vi è piaciuta la
mappa ragazze mi piace famiglia che sta
veramente era la più [ __ ] di tutti
dipende da un red la più bella cosa se
vi è piaciuto al suo documento è un mi
piace anche a parlare di facebook e
cavani video trattare tiziano servizi di
scrittrici diavolo fosse novita pero
ragazzi
[Musica]